welcome everyone as we are here to talk
about capital ones
the match
coming to you live friday november 26th
from las vegas at
wynn golf club on tnt
and we have one of the greatest
rivalries in the game of golf bryce's
day chambeau and brooks kepca
and we are really excited to have brooks
with us here to talk about the upcoming
match
i know for quite some time uh you have
been uh living red free in his dome and
i'm wondering what you've learned while
being
applied to this upcoming match
to give yourself an edge i personally
learned that he's a bit more of a softy
than i thought uh you know he just you
know played this hardball first off you
know as i kept pushing back a little bit
there was definitely some uh
unique responses that i got out of him
ones that i didn't really expect i
thought it'd be a little harder
than uh you know he he did i mean he
definitely
walking with spikes behind him he turned
around and rolled his eyes i mean i was
surprised at that i'm like man that that
shouldn't have bothered him in one bit
but you know that did obviously i mean
he said i may have said something i
don't know
um
you know and then him going out and
uh trying to incite crowds and not
having him man up and and talk to me
about it like you know it's just kind of
you know softball on me i guess you
could say he's trying to go through and
use social media as a platform to to
mess with me and
no we're gonna settle on the golf course
what are you worried about him learning
as much time as he had spent
rent free in your dome that he might
apply to this upcoming match
uh to help him perform well if he thinks
he's living in my head that's great he
can do it um
you were living in my head more after
the pga than he's ever been um i can
promise you that
i
man i can't believe this guy just did
this i was like
i'm all about bragging rights and
as you go head-to-head we're going to be
on the golf course together you and
bryson and i know that you're not really
one that likes to talk but i'm going to
be out there
trying to get your thoughts out i'm not
trying to get in your head or try to you
know do any games with you but i want
people to see
what it is that goes through your head
now we know uh bryson is very scientific
what what brings out the best in you how
are you your best when you're on the
golf course i mean i enjoy i enjoy it
when i'm having fun i think a lot of
times you only see a snippet right like
to be quite honest the reason i don't
talk a lot or you know they've got a
boom mic right there they've got a
camera you see a lot on the courses
you know
talking about whatever whatever it might
be with my caddy i'm not trying to let
the other players know what's up and
where this is it's a it's a lot
different it's one on one right i don't
care what he sees what
reaction um anything like that and a lot
of times we're just talking smack
and um you know this is this is a
different form of golf where
um you know trash star is more than
welcome i can say
you know
anything to him and and not feel bad
about
um you know ruining the guys round or
anything like that so look i'm looking
forward to that i'm looking forward to
the talk and and there's nothing more
that i'd love than than to walk away
after seven holes and this is actually
the second time you participated in the
match you you were winner
with aaron rodgers last time and and
really a lot of people in fact pretty
much everyone in the sports world has
been regarding that as
one of the great upsets in the history
of sports as like a tyson buster douglas
type upset and
i would like to know in your own words
how did you do it there's a lot of uh
help from the other partner i can tell
you that uh first and foremost though i
think brooks is trying to get his name
back um you know i've been taking that
name on for quite a while now it's time
for him to try and take it back
um but no i mean it was it was fun i had
a great partner
that uh led me uh to victory i mean he
made everything and i just had a couple
bombs and we unfortunately got got the
job done against y'all so it definitely
was one of the best upsets
in sports history
we have a shorter
match it's only 12 holes
i know that you're not a big fan of slow
play so we tried to shorten it up for
you to to give you that slight edge so
it would be a quicker a quicker match
uh but what about the win golf club are
you familiar with and how do you
anticipate
uh kind of attacking that golf course to
come out on top yeah i mean playing 12
holes is nice i mean it's better than
playing 18 holes with bryson so um
anything anything to spend less time
around him i'm i'm happy to do but yeah
you know being at the wind i i love it
there um i enjoy staying at the wind i
enjoy playing that golf course it's it's
a lot of fun i think there's a lot of a
lot of shorter holes um you know you see
a lot more
probably aggressive play you know what i
like is that the fact that tigers won 18
majors and i've only won six has never
really stopped me from talking smack in
regards to him
the fact that
he's won four major year one and it's
not stopping you at all from topping
talking smack and and i do really like
that i've won fedex got playoff
tournaments i've won tournaments that he
hasn't won yet in the memorial arnold
palmer so i'm not afraid i mean yeah
they're major championships for sure but
he just played all those weeks i mean
all those other
it's not a pga tour event or you know if
it's not if it's not a major right it
doesn't really show up there's a lot of
great rivalries in sports and you're
part of one of the best i guess i mean i
wouldn't say it's that big of a rivalry
i mean when you got four to one and the
one was during covet and i didn't play
so i mean i don't know how big of a
rivalry that could be
um
you know when you win a major and i'm
there then it might be more credible but
um like yours
you know i got i got spanked pretty good
but yeah
so you know four to one doesn't seem
too equivalent to me but yeah um i guess
i guess off the golf course yeah it
probably is a rivalry um plenty of john
i'm not afraid of it i'm not afraid i
can take it not afraid to give it so
okay let me now what i do
respect a lot is how the two of you will
have a rivalry and then
i saw you two work well together during
the ryder cup and breakfast
each other in the team not only were you
not a distraction for the team you both
became leaders
and helped the team and i'm curious now
after playing your second ryder cup what
your experience of that event has been
well in the ryder cup i think it's it's
about coming together as a team and this
past uh year at western stage we were
able to come together and even though
brooks and i didn't really agree on a
lot of things we haven't agreed on much
um we were able to set those differences
aside and we were like hey look this is
really good a team let's let's do it i'm
okay with it if uh comes to be where we
need to go out and play let's go and
play let's get it done for america so
from my perspective it couldn't have
ended any better this year
uh definitely losing in france put a
fire in my belly
on the europeans and i wanted to come
back out you know firing lost all my
matches and and i went and played really
well this time and didn't lose so
very pumped about that and i can tell
you that i'd want to do that for years
to come but it's nice to see people that
come together and i i love the team
aspect and atmosphere i wanted to to
talk to you quickly about rivalries
because as you and brooks uh showcase
one of the greatest rivalries in golf
and in all of sports there are other
great rivalries what's a rivalry that
you
looked up to as a kid were part of on
one side and what's it like to be a part
of one of those rivalries now well i
would say the best rivalry growing up
was between you and tiger i always love
watching you guys battle it out i
thought that was super amazing and cool
and albeit you know he got you a few
times you know most of the time you know
you still battled it out no matter what
and i love that
enthusiasm endurance and respect that i
i gained for you because of that you
have a drive an internal drive a work
ethic a motivation that is really uh
unlike very few i've ever seen and so
what is it like where does that stem
from where where is that uh
that passion that drive where does that
come from i can't stand legal that's my
biggest thing i i really just cannot
stand it
it eats away at me probably more than
um
i let on or would let anybody else know
in the room in the room um
you know me jenna's jenna's seen it
maybe
a handful of times but i'll i'll try to
do it behind closed doors
um and i mean it doesn't matter if we're
playing ping-pong pool
darts
cornhole it doesn't matter i want to i
want to embarrass you so bad um
to the point where i make you cry and i
i enjoy that and i enjoy watching
it's probably
ruthless but i enjoy watching everybody
else squirm while they're while they're
down or while they're while they're
having uh
you're not doing their best and i enjoy
capitalizing on that and making sure
you know you want to step on their
throats and i think that's that's one of
those
few things i idolized kobe growing up
man that's what um that's kind of what
he did and that's that's where i'm at
you have a huge heart i've seen it and
you have been very involved in multiple
charities uh
and i know you have on a local level i
know you have on a national level
and i know that uh
this event has raised more than 30
million for charities as well as feed
over 10 million meals to through
america
and tell us a little bit about some of
the charitable uh involvement that you
care about the the areas that really
absolutely the bryson duchamp foundation
supports uh three there's three pillars
to it so uh i mean again we raised a lot
of money for uh we reserved 10 million
meals feeding america you know last
match that was unbelievable i was so
excited to be a part of that i'll tell
you that the first part of my foundation
is junior golf i love junior golf i mean
i wouldn't be here in the game of golf
without junior golf and so jjnc and the
ncga junior tour i've been supporting
them for a few years now and
the next thing is health so my dad has
diabetes and i've been supporting the
national kitty foundation as well as the
shriners hospital
won their tournament in 2018 and
continue to work with them and then
lastly education we're trying to find a
good place uh to be put into in that
regard i've got a couple great ideas in
regards to education that i want to
implement into school systems and
whatever it is charter systems or
product systems
um you know we're still working on
dealing with that but we've raised a
good amount of money and we're
continuing to do so and i think we're
going to be working on getting one of my
charity events back in fresno where i
grew up and we had the save march
shootout a long time ago back in 2003
2004 my dad was the general manager of
the golf course out there and that was
my first exposure to professionals lee
trevino was out there arnold palmer was
out there annika sorensen was out there
um yeah
peter jake yeah i mean literally you
name it there's there's a bunch of
people out there that nick watney
another one and they all were super
supportive of me when i was 11. i got to
drive in front of them and that's what
inspired me to play professional golf uh
those guys showed me a great time
allowed me
to uh prove to myself that i can do it
in front of a crowd and that was a big
stepping stone for me to being
comfortable in playing golf so hats off
to them and charity work is a huge deal
in influencing
kids lives in a positive way is is
something that i'm hugely supportive
of so
do you have any final thoughts that you
feel uh might um
like you want to plant a seed in the
minds of your competitor brooks or the
fans something to watch out for come
friday november 26th well just know that
brooks and i have never been paired
together in competition any sorts on the
pga tour or anywhere else this is gonna
be the first time that we're together
playing against each other you may see
some something pretty interesting in
regards to the mental competition that
we're going to play against each other
was there a final thought that you might
want to add is to just kind of plant a
seed into
bryson's head or the public's head as to
what's about to come
listen i'm doing my research
i've always done my research before i
speak so
i'm gonna keep doing it
um but just know this is this is gonna
be different than any other event and
you better watch out you better watch
out on the golf course and then
you know
that microphone or uh be right there in
his ear so he'll hear everything well
i'm proud that capital one's the match
are is bringing the two of you together
for the first time and we're going to
have it live on tnt friday november 26th
from the wynn golf club in las vegas
thanks phil appreciate the time it's
going to be amazing it's going to be
awesome so thanks for being on thanks
for being a part of this i appreciate
it'll be fun man can't wait